this volume your first step is you've
got to form the RAC integral you've got
to form the right integral so let's just
remember not that it's some the
important part that gets you marks but
what is the general formula for the
volume of a solid of revolution how do
you form it you start with your pi times
the integral R and then you sneak in
whatever boundaries okay now what's the
integrand it's y squared right and it's
with respect to X and you can know
because that's the way you're rotating
okay so that's the way I think about it
because if you want X 2 dy that you
going the other way okay
now if that's our setup okay we can I'm
substituting the right things that are
relevant to our questions so let's try
that
right the void is equal to PI what our
batteries not too high and fall yeah
watch out I've seen a couple of you make
this error it's 1 plus 10x right so
clearly you can see if I just taking
regular tedx right I wouldn't quite get
this shape statics goes through the
origin so I'd get on I get a pointy
teeth right I wouldn't have a nice flat
surface there okay because you just have
that and that would be what's rotated
okay so therefore you have to account
for that in your integral this is one
plus 10x more squared okay
or square finally important right we
spent some time looking at why you can't
just do square bits individually but all
right then you can expand that out even
though you might be tempted think oh is
there any reverse chain rule business
even actually expanding will let us use
some identities that we know right so
the expansion of course is 1 plus 2 10 X
plus 10 squared okay and that's gonna be
useful to us in a second all right so
what's your first identity that you can
use to work with this one understand
squared what's it equal to again is it's
x squared or is 10 squared equals x
squared plus 1 which one is it
how can you be sure okay go back to this
always come back to this right because
we can reliably get this right whereas
under exams we can muddle this up and
I've seen some of you do exactly that
okay so I guess what would you do to
this to divide everything by cos squared
wouldn't you okay so you can see that 1
plus 10 squared that's going to result
of that
wave remembering it do I dare ask or did
it work how did you do it should I
should I finish my explanation first and
then he can tell me okay fine all right
now you look at this sex squared you
know how to integrate right what is it
interior to that'll become tan right but
to tan X what do we do with that okay do
you remember now because it's slide over
cause right let's figure out this on the
side is if this is all I have to worry
about okay this is almost almost F dash
F isn't it it's not quite though what
would I have to do to make it f - enough
I need a negative in there
and I'll slap without the French to make
sure okay
so soon as it's after - on F what is the
it's rule it's log of F right don't
forget the minus sign
okay so that's what we would have if we
just had regular 1002 now we've got two
of them so no big deal I'll just double
it
from not to buy on for bigger I think
that's the hard work but for the sake of
it we can't evaluate this
right so I'm gonna call it for myself
okay so let's do this
don't forget your pie at the front
please it's an easy thing to just
disappear right what I got here
tear to plan for ya - to log closed
platform now there's a lot of
simplifying you can do it here okay when
you actually evaluate even though it
looks a bowl full right now okay what's
the other boundary now you look at it
right I know it's going on one of its
going to vanish but you can't not write
it okay you have to show the understand
what this means that's why you got
evaluate the pieces okay either if they
do end up being truthful so you got tan
0 minus 2 log cause they go happy
this time though 10.4 one cosplay for
102 yeah one on two okay
think about that come back for one
second 1000 to log of one Lord one is
just it's just zero okay great that's
good now that one not much to do with it
right but one over to you know help us
if we can write us an index form right
why why am I really going to eat next
form because you got warlords who can
working here to simplify things right so
this is to log what to the power of
negative 1/2 1/2 is the square root and
the negative is the fraction okay and
you can see what's going to happen here
right this is going to come out the
front and it's going to exactly cancel
in fact the negatives going to cancel
and the twos gonna cancel so you'll get
that yeah so therefore the volume is and
then you can slap your unit on